I passed on investing in Uber from one
of my best friends twice had I made a
normal 25 000 investment like I was
doing at the time I would have made
somewhere close to 500 million dollars
the reason it doesn't even sit with me
is I also know had I've done that my
life would have been completely
different and I don't know that that
would have meant that I would have found
myself in Shanghai one night for a
business meeting that that would have
led me to and maybe not paying attention
I would have been hit by a car and died
I believe that you're scared to like
lose that's why you're not doing
anything and that it feels better to
make pretend you're capable instead of
seeing if you're capable you know what I
mean you're protecting yourself people
are posturing the reason you're hurting
inside is you know you're acting but
inside you know you're scared of
you're scared that's why you're not
doing you're not scared of missing out
on the alternative you're scared of
doing because if you do then you might
fail you got to practice losing my man
instead of making pretend you won't lose